[موسيقى]
الشهر الثالث من شهور السنه الميلاديه
يسمى بشهر مارس وهو احد سبعه شهور الذي
يتكون من 31 يوما وكلمه مارس مشتقه من
ماريوتوس الرومانيه والتي تعني الهه الحرب
يسمى بالعراق وبلاد الشام بادار ماخوذه من
هدره البابليه والتي تعني هدير سواحبي
والعواصف فهذا موطنها والعامه عندنا
يسمونه بابا ذر وقالوا اذا طلع ابا دار
ابرضت الاشجار وافرخت الاطيار وتساوى
الليل مع النهار وتعلل الجار مع الجار
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فمع بدايه شهر مارس تبدا الامراض الموسميه
الحساسيه بجميع انواعها والزكام وفي منتصف
شهر مارس يتساوى في طول الليل مع النهار
وفي نهايته موسم برد بياع الخبل عباته وهو
البرد الذي ياتينا بعد دفء صيفي والعرب
القدماء يسمونه ببرد الحسوم وهو البرد
الذي اهلك الله به قوم عاد سخرها عليهم
سبع ليالي وثمانيه ايام حسومه فترى القوم
فيها صرعه كانهم اعجاز نخل
خاويه
[موسيقى]